hey this is presh talwalkar
a binary operation star is defined by x
star y
is equal to the sum of x and y
divided by one plus x times y
evaluate the following
first evaluate 2 star 3
take the result star 4
take the result star 5 and so on and the
pattern continues until the final
operation
which is the result star 2021
i think boomi for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
to solve a problem like this you want to
start out by evaluating some examples
what is two star three
it's equal to the sum of two and three
divided by one plus two times three
this is equal to five over seven
for the next operation we take five over
7 star 4.
we substitute in and then we simplify to
get the result 11 over 9.
we then want 11 over 9 star 5
we substitute in and get the result of
seven over eight
we then want seven over eight star six
this is equal to eleven over ten
we now search for a pattern in these
results
notice in the first two fractions
the denominator and the numerator differ
by two
so let's rewrite the last two results
seven over eight is equal to fourteen
over 16 and 11 over 10 is equal to 22
over 20.
let's say the first result is a3 the
next result is a4 then we have a5 and a6
so after studying these fractions we can
come up with the following pattern
we will hypothesize that a n
is equal
to the following
we have n multiplied by n plus 1 divided
by 2 minus 1
all over n multiplied by n plus 1 over 2
plus 1.
so this is the sum of numbers to n
minus 1 in the numerator and the sum of
the numbers to n plus 1 for the
denominator and this is for n being an
odd number
if we have an even number we'll flip the
numerator and denominator
so this holds for all of the examples
we've calculated
so assuming this is true
what would a of
2021 be equal to
we can substitute in
and then we can
simplify the fraction will be equal to
one million twenty one thousand six
hundred and fifteen divided by one
million twenty one thousand six hundred
and sixteen
and that's the answer
now to be a hundred percent sure we have
to prove this formula is true
in order to do that let's rewrite the
fractions
we'll multiply the numerator and
denominator by 2
so we have n multiplied by n plus one
minus two divided by n multiplied by n
plus one plus two
the other fraction will be the
reciprocal of this
we will show this formula is true
using mathematical induction we've
already shown it's true for some base
cases such as n is equal to 3 and n is
equal to 4. now suppose k is a natural
number greater than or equal to 3.
we need to show that if the formula is
true for k that it's true for k plus one
we will split it up into two cases where
k is odd and k is even
suppose first that k is odd
a k plus one is equal to a k star k plus
1.
since k is an odd number we can use the
formula for ak by the induction
hypothesis
we'll substitute in
we now need to do some simplification
i'm going to skip over the nitty-gritty
details and just show you a couple steps
of the proof
here's one intermediate step and then
once we do simplification we get the
following fraction
this is exactly the fraction we want for
ak plus 1.
so we've proven this step
now we do the case where k is an even
number
it's a very similar calculation a k plus
1 is equal to a k star k plus 1 by the
induction hypothesis we know the formula
for ak we substitute in and then we do
simplification and we show that the
formula is in fact true for ak plus 1.
so we verified this step
thus the formula is true and that
completes the proof
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]
you